-To my right,
America's sweetheart
and veteran "Password" player,
Betty White.
-Where?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Who are you
playing with, Betty?
-I'm playing with John
from Dallas.
-Oh, fantastic.
-And we're winning.
I should say, we're winning.
-John and I are winning.
-Oh, good.
-I've gotta beat him
no matter what happens.
[ Laughter ]
-And to my left, host of NBC's
"Late Night with Jimmy Fallon"
and Saugerties' sweetheart,
Jimmy Fallon.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Who's your partner
tonight, Jimmy?
-Kiss it.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-This is Stephanie from
Detroit, Michigan, right here.
My partner,
and we are gonna win.
Because that's the way we do it.
We play fair and play hard.
-Well, hard, anyway.
-Yeah. Let's go, you guys.
We're here to play "Password"!
Come on!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
-I'm your host, Steve Higgins.
The rules of the game
are very simple.
I will give each of you
a password.
Then, each of you
are to give a one-word clue --
one-word clue only --
to get your partner
to guess the password.
Scoring starts at 6 points.
We take away a point each time
the clue is passed.
You have 5 seconds each time.
-[ Laughs ]
-Remember, no part or form
of the password can be used.
Watch the gestures, Jimmy.
This is not charades.
Just telling you now.
Clue is illegal,
you will hear this...
[ Buzzer buzzes ]
...and you'll forfeit your turn.
Any questions?
-Oh.
-John, we're gonna
start with you.
-The password is...
-Dork.
Dork.
-Dork? Oh.
[ Stammers ] Idiot.
[ Laughter ]
-Jimmy, 5 points.
Stephanie.
-Dweeb.
-Nerd.
-Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
There you go.
-Come on, let's get it!
-I want to help him all I can --
give him a little handicap.
Yeah, you want a little
handicap there.
You don't want
to crush him that --
-Absolutely. I was hoping
it wasn't my name.
Give me those --
I'll throw them in the garbage.
Jimmy, Betty.
-Look, I got into it by myself.
-The password is...
-Jimmy? Your turn.
6 points.
[ Laughter ]
-Treasure.
-Hunt?
-Ooh.
-Boobs.
[ Laughter ]
-John, you're getting excited --
-Booty.
-Booty, booty.
-Um...
-There you go, Jimmy.
-Breasts.
[ Laughter ]
It's the weirdest thing.
I'm so sorry.
-Um...
-There we go.
-Gold -- I don't know.
-Betty? 3 points.
-Treasure...
-Island.
[ Laughter ]
-2 points, Stephanie.
You got it.
-Jimmy, come on.
-Trunk.
-Chest.
-Oh.
-There you go.
-Yeah, all right.
-Very good.
-Whew!
7-0.
-You don't seem very happy
over there.
-Oh, I'm happy as a lark.
[ Laughter ]
-Stephanie? John?
-The password is...
-Okay. Stephanie,
it's your call.
-Cocktail.
-Drink.
-I-I didn't hear the clue.
-Oh, cocktail.
She said cocktail.
He said drink.
They were both wrong.
-Right, I like that part.
I like that part.
-Olive.
-Martini.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow!
-Yes!
-Ding-ding-ding-ding-ding.
School's in session.
-[ Laughs ]
-[ Goofy voice ]
School is in session.
-[ Stammers ]
[ Laughter ]
-School!
All right, Betty, Jimmy.
-Yes.
The password is...
-That doesn't help me at all.
-See it or hear it.
-All right, yeah.
You have to say it louder.
-All right, Betty,
you give the clue.
-Okay, uh...
-[ Goofy exclamation ]
Okay.
-Do I give the clue?
-No, Betty gives the clue.
-Oh, okay.
Uh...
Room.
-Um...
chair.
-Ooh, no.
Jimmy.
-Paint?
-You're good.
-Wall?
-[ Squeaks ]
[ Laughter ]
[ All exclaiming ]
All right, Betty's turn.
-Flowered...
-Wallpaper.
-Oh!
[ Indistinct chatter ]
-The winner!
-Oh!
-We're 9-7! You wo-- [ Laughs ]
-You are the greatest!
-9-7!
[ Bell dinging ]
To my right
is America's sweetheart
and veteran "Password" player,
Betty White.
-Are you America's sweetheart?
-Who are you
playing with, Betty?
-I'm playing with Will
from Brooklyn, New York.
-All right.
-And to my left,
the host of NBC's
"Late Night with Jimmy Fallon"
and Saugerties' sweetheart,
James Thomas Fallon.
Jimmy, who's your
partner tonight?
-Uh, my partner is Kendra
from Center Point, Indiana.
Kendra, we're --
we're gonna play "Password"!
♪♪
-I'm your host, Steve Higgins.
The rules of the game
are very simple.
I will give each of you
a password,
then each of you are to give
a one-word clue.
That's one word only.
-What's that? Anything?
Two words? No.
One word to get
your partner to guess.
The scoring starts at 6.
We take away a point
each time the clue passes.
You have five seconds
to get a guess each clue,
and remember --
no part of the form
or anything of the word
can be used.
This isn't charades, Jimmy,
so no cheating.
If a clue is illegal
as determined by our judges,
you will hear this...
[ Buzzer buzzes ]
...and you'll forfeit the turn.
The team with the most
after 6, wins.
Any questions?
-No, but I just have to say
I've heard that speech before,
and I married the man
in the middle.
-Well...
-And we would have been married
48 years today.
-Oh, really?
-Wow!
[ Cheers and applause ]
He was a great man, Allen.
He really was.
Okay. Ready, you guys?
I'm about to cry.
That was sweet.
Okay, first clues
goes to Betty and Jimmy.
Barry, why don't you
start us off?
-Getting...
-Okay, ready?
-...in here is the tough part.
-Mm-hmm, mm-hmm.
There you go.
-Mm-hmm.
[ Laughter ]
-After you.
-No, aprés vous.
-Ah! [ Laughs ]
W-Wave.
-Ocean?
-[ Goofy voice ] Ooh, no.
[ Laughter ]
-Uh, riding.
-Surf...fing.
-Ooh.
[ Laughter ]
-Wooden.
-Surfboard?
-Yes!
[ Bell dinging ]
Not that I'm familiar.
-I thought I aced her.
I thought I'm the good guy here,
and you barked back at me.
Shame on you.
-I'm so psyched.
-Okay. Oh, here we go.
-The password is...
-Okay, we'll start with you.
-All right, can do.
-Got it?
-Like.
-Huh?
[ Laughter ]
Facebook.
-Yeah!
-Oh! Oh!
-Oh!
-Didn't miss at all!
-Oh! Oh, are you ready?
Are you ready?
This is it, right here.
-Oh, my goodness.
This is it right here.
-I guess I should say,
last time Betty was here,
she beat me at beer pong,
and I haven't lived it down
to this day,
so I'm going for the win.
I'm going for the jugular.
-Oh, my!
-I'm going for the win.
-Okay.
-That was great!
-Thank you.
-Good job.
-Thanks.
-All right, ready?
-Okay.
The password is...
-Would you speak
a little louder?
It would help.
-Yeah. We'll start with Betty.
-Okay.
-Got it?
-Uh-huh.
Okay?
-Yep.
-Weenie.
[ Laughter ]
-Watch it. Watch it, Will.
-Weenie.
[ Laughter ]
-Hot dog.
-That's two words.
-Hmm.
[ Laughter ]
-Nathan's.
-Hot dog stand?
I don't know.
-Mm. Judges?
No.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-You didn't even look at --
No, sorry.
-Well, I'm sorry.
-Okay.
-Uh...
Weenie.
[ Laughter ]
[ Indistinct ]
-Right. That is a good clue.
-Stick with it.
-Bun.
-Buns.
[ Light laughter ]
-Hamburger.
[ Laughter ]
-Bun? I don't know.
-Oh.
That's a good strategy.
[ Laughter ]
-Other.
Mustard.
-Hmm.
-Wiener.
-Anthony.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-That's a good one.
-Right?
-Okay, man,
-Wiener.
[ Laughter ]
-Fries?
-Oh.
-Weiner fries, yeah.
What if --
what if I was to say --
I don't mean to Dick Clark it,
but what if you were to say
Vienna?
-Stop it, you can't play.
Vienna.
Alright, so we don't
get that one.
-No, that was it.
The answer was...
-Frankfurter.
Oh, you know what?
Here's the trouble.
No one remembers who
Frankfurter is anymore.
Remember him?
-Yes, Frankfurter.
I knew the whole Furter family.
Frank, Gina,
they're all nice people.
[ Laughter ]
-The password is mermaid.
-Here we go.
-Okay, well, you're ready?
We're gonna start with Will.
-Atlantis.
-I didn't hear you.
-Continent.
[ Laughter ]
-Disney?
-Disney.
Oh.
Mermaid.
-Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's it.
That's it. We're great.
-Yeah.
-Come on, this is it.
We got it.
This is fantastic.
-Welcome back to "Late Night."
To my right is America's
sweetheart
and veteran password player,
Ms. Betty White
-Oh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And who are you
playing with, Betty.
-Yeah, I'm playing
with Amberley, and guess what?
Today is her 30th birthday.
[ Cheers and applause ]
So take pity on us.
-Alright. I'll be nice,
I'll be nice.
-And to my right is host of
NBC's "Late Night,"
Jimmy Fallon.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And who's -- who's your partner?
Jimmy, is it?
-Ah, my partner --
Thank you, my name is Jimmy.
Thank you.
[ Laughter ]
This is my --
this is my pal,
Saad from Brooklyn, New York.
-Oh yeah.
[ Laughter ]
And we are all here
to play Password!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-And I am your host,
Steve Higgins.
The rules of the game
are very simple.
I will give each of you
a password,
then each of you
are to give a one-word clue,
one word only to get
your partner
to guess the password.
The scoring starts
at six points.
We take away one
for each time it passes.
You have five seconds
to guest each time.
Remember, no part or form
of the password can be used.
[ Snoring ]
-And if a clue is found
to be illegal by our judges,
you'll hear this.
[ Buzzer ]
-[ Snorts ]
-And you'll forfeit the turn.
[ Laughter ]
-And the player
with the most points...
-You're still talking?
-...percent,
guess does what they do?
-What?
-They win.
-There you go.
-Any questions? Great.
Alright.
First clue,
Betty and Jimmy.
We're going to start
with you, Betty.
-Come on, Saad, we can do this.
-The password is 10 tattoo.
[ Laughter ]
-It's stuck in there, isn't it?
There we go.
-Can I show my partner?
-No, that's against rules.
-Alright.
-You know that, you know that.
-Okay.
-Start with you, Betty.
-Start with me?
-Yup.
-Alrighty.
Good luck, sweetheart.
[ Light laughter ]
Uh, needle
-Thread.
-Jimmy.
-Plane.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Helicopter.
[ Laughter ]
-Picture.
-Movie.
-Ink.
-Needle, ink, plane.
[ Laughter ]
-Pen.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-Arm.
-Leg.
-Put them together.
[ Laughter ]
-This is not Charades, sir.
-Unh-unh, unh-unh.
-Words.
It's called Password.
Not Pass -- Pass action.
-Sorry, you're right.
Sorry, sorry. Okay, yeah.
Uh, mother.
[ Laughter ]
-Mother?
-That is a nice tattoo.
-Oh!
-That would be tattoo.
Tattoo.
Oh! One point.
[ Dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Only one point.
-Wow.
It's only one point.
-One point is still a point.
Saad, there, you take that.
-Thank you.
-Birthday girl.
-We'll start with you.
-The password is stocking.
-I'll take this.
I'll throw it in the garbage.
-Okay.
-Stuffer.
-Hurt.
[ Laughter ]
-Stuffer, yeah.
-Sock.
-Oh.
-I didn't hear, I'm sorry.
-Sock.
-Oh.
-Stuffer, sock.
Sounds like my high
school prom.
[ Laughter ]
-Hmm, is that a cucumber?
-Stuffer, sock.
-Puppet?
-Eh.
-No.
-Christmas.
-Uh...
Stocking.
[ Dinging ]
-Four points.
Wow.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Stuffer, sock.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Yes, stocking.
Of course stocking.
-Jimmy, we'll start with you.
-Yes.
-The password is woodpecker.
[ Laughter ]
-Hmm.
[ Laughs ] Whoo!
-I have a wonderful clue,
but I don't think it's usable.
-No, no, no, no.
[ Laughter ]
We're on network television.
Yeah, we got a...
Let me go. Okay.
Bird.
[ Laughter ]
-Chicken?
-It's a bird.
-Uh...
Tree.
-Nest.
[ Laughter ]
-Ah, ah, ah, ah.
-Watch the hands.
-Alright, alright.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Cartoon.
-Cartoon?
-Woody Woodpecker.
-Whoa!
[ Dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wow.
-I know, I know.
-Now we'll start with you.
-I can't move my hands.
I'll keep my hands to...
-To yourself.
-...too myself, thank you.
-The password is mustache.
-Never mind.
-Saad, you go first.
-Um...
-I'm focusing up.
[ Light mustache ]
-Goatee.
[ Laughter ]
-Beard?
-No.
-Handlebar
-Mustache.
-Oh!
[ Dinging ]
Wow.
-That was very good.
-This is a barn burner.
One more round.
-We are -- are we close?
-There we go.
What's the score?
-9-5.
-9-5, boom, boom, boom, boom.
-The password is sausage.
[ Laughter ]
-Slow down.
We're starting with Betty.
-Surprise you didn't do
your Christmas party hat.
-Yeah
-We start with...?
-You.
-Pepperoni.
-Sausage.
-Oh!
-The best!
-Yeah!
Betty White
and the birthday girl
are the best!
[ Dinging ]